this is the best known example of Chuck
Hoberman's work it's called the
Hoberman's sphere and it's one of the
most iconic toys to come out of the 90s
I didn't expect that the sphere would
become such a popular toy and it wasn't
what I was actually looking for what he
was actually after was much more
ambitious my career has been about an
unusual form of design and it's about a
question that I asked myself how can I
make an object transform the way we see
clouds transforming in the sky or a time
lapse of a flower unfolding what if we
could make objects physical objects in
our lives that actually do that over the
past several decades he's designed all
kinds of transformable objects from toys
and it turns inside out to large
structures to materials like these which
might one day be used to build pop-up
shelters for disaster relief or scaled
way way down to create things like
better stents for cardiac patients but
to understand how this all works there's
really only one place to start this is
the Hoberman's sphere people look at it
and they go well how does it do that
and it's a funny question to me because
it's not like a piece of electronics or
it's hidden away in a box you see
everything about the sphere it's doing
it really because of the magic of
geometry there's about 400 individual
plastic pieces and you can see that
there are Pentagon's and triangles but
it's also made up of six rings that
intersect each other to form those
shapes but of course the unique thing
about it is that the shapes are not
static
they're dynamic I'm putting energy into
this to make it open and close but my
motions are just a push and a pull the
transformation is the 400 individual
pieces all moving along their program
path towards the center of the sphere
like that and then radiating out
expanding universe style like that and a
lot of what I do is about that basic
trick taking a pusher of pull and
converting that energy into the process
of physical transformation oddly enough
the Hoberman's sphere wasn't actually
designed to be a toy I wasn't really a
toy maker I could back to my way into
that for me is the author of it I was
interested in all this serious stuff and
yet somehow this fascination with math
and materials and mechanics became
something that a five-year-old could
relate to perfectly at first it was just
about solving an engineering problem how
to create a sphere that could
shape-shift in a natural way
after several dead ends he discovered a
new way to make a simple scissor
mechanism that is two links connected by
a pivot and that mechanism had a unique
geometric property as it unfolded the
angle formed by its endpoints didn't
change you can see that here with the
dotted lines in other words he can now
design a sphere that changes its size
while maintaining the same shape by
figuring out the geometry he was able to
build this an 800-pound motorized sphere
that still suspended in New Jersey's
Liberty Science Center it's been there
for about 25 years opening and closing
all day long one thing he noticed early
on is that kids were especially drawn to
it that's when a light bulb went off I
thought you know something maybe we
could just put this in a box and sell it
as a toy after the sphere put him on the
map he started getting opportunities and
entertainment like this giant aluminum
curtain he created for the 2002 Winter
Olympics or the 4,000 square-foot
shape-shifting video screen that his
firm co-produced for u2's 360 tour more
recently he helped with the initial
concept for the Atlanta Falcons new
retractable roof which opens and closes
like an iris beyond all these wildly
different projects is one central idea
something he calls transformable design
most design objects are static through
their lifetime and eventually they're
just supposed to
I'm looking for kind of a different
angle on it which is what if those
objects were dynamic and alive and in
movement around us in order to create
new experiences of course but also to
give us actual functional benefits
Hoberman started out as a sculptor
before getting his master's in
engineering and he brings an artistic
eye to all of his projects but many of
his designs have functional uses - where
is transformation going where is this
concept going there's so many different
possibilities adaptive buildings would
be one buildings where the space will
transform according to different uses
where you might have a big open lobby
that lots of rooms can suddenly appear
as needed and then disappear when
they're not needed or for a more
practical example take this tent I
designed it's 800 square feet and it
would normally take hours to assemble
this version goes up in minutes to see
how it works take a look at the
miniature version all of the pieces are
hinged together so there's no need to
assemble it one piece at a time but
these days he's moving beyond his
classic joints and hinges approach
thanks to a surprisingly old-school
technique origami up until about 20
years ago origami was a craft at an art
now it's a topic of math engineering
robotics structures that's being studied
in all of its full glory think of it a
flat sheet can be folded into a bird say
but mathematicians have actually shown
that a flat sheet can be folded into any
shape at all what I think of when I do
that is not how can I transform that
sheet with all of this very complicated
folding with my hands but how can I do
it where you push a button and it folds
from flat to form automatically his
latest obsession is to design
large-scale origami structures that will
expand
at the push of a button the building he
cuts out sheets of plastic with this
robotic arm and then connects them
together in various shapes there's some
really challenging problems there's the
challenge of what materials you use and
especially the challenge of how do you
actually make a big origami structure
get bigger and smaller
what is the automation of it what is
what are the motors or the forces that
you need to make the transformation
happen and the area that I've identified
that seems very promising is inflation
this is an origami piece that's wrapped
with a seal so that we can inflate it
and deflate it I'm going to put on air
pressure now and you'll see it inflate
and then I can put a vacuum on and that
will pull it close breakthroughs and
origami design could lead to all kinds
of new inventions from foldable
furniture and buildings to micro
robotics and non-invasive medical
devices why do I want to make objects
transform I could say it's to help
humanity and I think in some sense it is
but it's because I'm an inventor and I
love coming up with ideas that have not
been tried out before
[Music]